hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I am dead where are my
keys hi Tina you gotta go lay down you
gotta go lay down pretty girl gon go lay
down
she likes to steal my socks when she
thinks I'm not looking but I know this
game is I don't know wow what a spooky
night out tonight I know right
Halloween never used to be this spooky
don't you agree skeletony skeletony
skeletony yes Wow I do agree it is very
scary out Skelly t o neurochip hi what
the is that a giant cat skeleton
that just knocked out the buildings in
the entire neighborhood boy this
Halloween sure is the spookiest that
I've ever seen I found here too yeah
it's an emergency
oh you're here to help us I guess oh hey
big skull yeah this is a perfectly
normal occurrence in this weird skeleton
neighborhood Halloween's in danger again
will you help Steve save it yeah all
right okay come with me
oh we must unite the candy once more
Roger that big skull we owe you one
anyways Oh God oh hello everybody I'm
actually waving that arm hey I don't
know what benefit this is gonna be for
me in this adventure but here we go I
guess oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god get the candy get the candy hello
hi I'll take some of that can I get some
of that glist candy I don't know how to
holy I'm stuck on a goddamn oh my
god when I find um ow
apparently when I find like indie games
and when I say indie games I mean
indie games when I find any game
sometimes it's always so it's always a
wrap the candy god damn it
just grab the goddamn candy there are
six more candy to find oh god I don't
know what this is it's like the Triforce
gotta reach into the house and get it
whoa somehow I think that house got
turned on by me grabbing it which is
very bizarre candy oh it's like embedded
in the house I gotta somehow reach
underneath the house is weird skirt and
thank you okay I'm just gonna skeleton
as my way around whoa can't touch that
with my bony hand I don't know if I want
to experience the risk that this game
has to offer am i driving through space
I just realized I'm not actually driving
on the ground
I'm I'm like I'm legitimately Am I
thank you my buds there are four more
kill I am driving through space when did
that happen I okay I'm no fool I'm
pretty 100% sure that I was driving on
the ground and that gravity was was was
my master and I had to obey oh god I did
it again okay to the left to the right
oh my god
mm mm II grabbed it and and boy got it
okay two left girl I see one more oh
yeah boink boink boink yeah boy there we
go finally just one more candy well I
wonder where that would be oh I see it
hello big skull how you doing big champ
how you doing big squeeze how you doing
my main man how you doing must skele
buddy whoa whoa I'm legitimately
terrified for my entire life
in my entire existence got it whoa where
did I go hello yes thank you okay four
wide I don't know what it did I don't
know why I'm doing all seven candies are
gathered in one place we can save
Halloween okay how I'm not sure by the
power of trick-or-treat okay oh I wish
for Halloween to be saved
oh we're making a wish now I didn't
realize I'm glad we saved Halloween it's
my favorite I don't think anyone even
knew was in danger
Skelly T went on to be a successful
divorce attorney
remember to floss regularly that is the
most important thing o bone nut you know
you know those games that you play it's
like a monumental moment in your life
that changes everything you think about
the universe of what you're in Marvins
I'm going to look at life differently
now that I know that I helped save
Halloween with Skelly tea and big skull
and skeleton e whoa so anyway hopefully
your life was just as changed and moved
and oh my god I'm so sorry if that
destroyed your entire reality like you
did my own but thank you everybody so
much for watching you can play this game
for yourself if you really want to
through the link in the description
below thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video